[Music]
I've been playing around with a really
amazing
it's a map of the solar system recently
I got really curious and I started to
zoo me out well past the solar system
and deep into the night sky and this
kind of blew my mind we have mapped
these stars that are so far away from us
light-years away and yet here they are
on this map
somehow positioned in space this seems
impossible to me how is it that we're
able to from this little speck of dust
look up and somehow gauge how far away
things are like this one specific star
how do we know that this is eight
hundred and sixty four point three
light-years away I mean that's like
eight quadrillion kilometers it's
insanely far the story of how we did
this how we measured the distance to
these incredibly faraway objects in the
sky it's a story of people looking up
and asking questions and in the process
creating a map of the heavens in the old
days people knew about the planets but
they thought the stars were in some sort
of vault of heaven just a bit further
away than the planets
so mapping the night sky this is a big
topic let's start small first the stuff
close to us how do we know how far
Jupiter is and the moon and all of that
from here the methods get trickier and
trickier the further away you get but
for now the solar system measuring the
distance the planets is relatively easy
because we see the planets move we see
them spin around the Sun and we can
observe their behavior over the course
of decades and generations and record
that after a lot of observation we
realized that the planets go around the
Sun and they go in this kind of
elliptical shape they don't go like in a
perfect circle you can then observe that
the planets start moving quicker the
closer they are to the Sun because of
gravity gravity pulls it in and whips it
around observing the planets and how
they move around the Sun allowed one
very smart german astronomer who
apparently exclusively ate with
chopsticks I'm kidding I know they're
not chopsticks okay it's just a joke
it's actually just like a compass hahaha
anyway this guy Johannes Kepler used his
chopsticks to measure all of this
movement how the planets moved he
plotted it and he came up with some
really savvy equations and ratios and
laws that gave us the average distance
to each planet suddenly the night sky
went from 2d to 3d for the first time
which gave us a place a physical place
relative to all these planets floating
around the Sun okay but this is child's
play when it comes to measuring
distances in space these planets are
like our next-door neighbors
so now let's step into the big leagues
and talk about how we started to map
stars and their distance from Earth
for the stuff that's not orbiting the
Sun that's really far away we can use a
concept called parallax wait a minute
parallax parallax sounds strangely
familiar when talking about physics and
space it was alright and it was said
that but he goes by the pseudonym
parallax that's that great name ok no no
not that parallax the pseudo scientist
from the 1800s I'm talking about the
scientific concept parallax is a concept
that says that if you're observing
something far away and you shift your
position relative to that far away thing
the far away thing will look slightly
different relative to the background ok
so let's say we're looking up at the
night sky and we want to know how far
away this star is remember that Earth is
always floating around the Sun at any
given time which is moving us in space
so if we observe this star in May and
then wait six months till November and
observe that star again we've now gained
a new perspective on the star and what
it looks like relative to its background
this gives us an angle that we can use
to calculate this distance what we don't
know is this value this is the distance
this is what we're looking for but we do
know a few things we know this distance
because it's just the distance from
Earth to the Sun which happens to be 149
million kilometers or one astronomical
unit so this distance times two and then
we also know this angle up here because
we measured it from two different
perspective thanks to the wizardry that
is trigonometry we can use this distance
and this angle to determine what this
distance is this works really well and
it's allowed us to measure the distance
to a lot of stars but remember that a
key ingredient to this whole parallax
thing is the slight shift in perspective
between the first angle and the second
angle as you start to measure things
that are further and further away this
angle becomes slider and slider until
eventually it becomes impossible to
discern it's so minuscule the
perspective shift that you can't
actually detect it so there's a limit to
how far parallax goes with our
earth-based telescopes we've been able
to perceive the angle enough to where we
can see things that are about 300
light-years away I mean that is way
bigger than like the things that are
close to us in the solar system but it's
still a tiny number compared to like the
galaxy or the universe luckily we have
fancier tools like this guy that have
really good technology for detecting
these slight angle differences from
tooten perspectives of a star and that's
allowed us to observe and measure the
distance to stars that are up to 3,000
light years away way further out okay so
here's where we're at with Kepler's
fancy equations watching the planets
move around the Sun we've been able to
measure the distance to planets with
parallax we've been able to measure the
distance to stars that are really far
away and get a 3d map of our galactic
neighbors but we're still not really
scratching the surface of the distances
that exist in the universe so how do we
do that
[Music]
this is where it starts to get kind of
crazy and tricky and weird and I'm gonna
do my best to explain this in a way that
comes through so here we go
one of the major methods for measuring
the distance to super far away stars and
galaxies was pioneered by a computer at
Harvard in 1912 what a computer in 1912
yeah that's what I said a computer at
Harvard in tanking but computers were
invented no to the 1950s but computers
in 1912 looked like this this is a group
of women who worked in Harvard's
Astronomy Department in the early 1900's
their job title was literally computers
meaning someone who executes
predetermined logical calculations on
large inputs of data Harvard astronomers
were taking loads of photos of the night
sky with their new fancy telescopes the
images came out like this glass plates
with photos of the night sky developed
on them the computers were tasked with
looking at each of these plates and
naming and classifying the Stars by
their brightness and their type
they were basically creating a 2d map of
the sky they didn't know how far away
they were they just were classifying
their position in the night sky relative
to our perspective on earth at the time
a lot of legit astronomers figured that
what was in our galaxy was all there was
to the universe we had no idea of
knowing how far away some of these
objects were so we just figured that
maybe everything is somewhat close by in
our galaxy one of these computers was
named Henrietta she was assigned to
focus on one big cluster of stars in the
night sky and to look at and classify
those stars she documented thousands of
stars but was bothered by this one
question if you look up at the night sky
and you see a super bright star is it
super bright because it's a big bright
star or is it super bright because it's
just close by by the same token if you
see a really dim star does that mean
it's just really really far away and
it's actually a big star that's super
bright or it's actually just a small dim
star we really had no way of knowing
because again they had no idea how far
away these objects were that they were
measuring she was looking at this one
part
of the night sky this one cloud of stars
she didn't know how far away that cloud
was but she figured all the stars were
about the same distance from her and she
noticed that some of these stars were
pulsating they were getting brighter and
dimmer brighter and dimmer and they were
doing it at a strangely consistent rate
if one of the stars took four days to
get brighter and it took four days to
get dimmer and four days to get brighter
it would stick to that pattern that
period over and over again very reliable
very consistent you may be wondering
what does this have to do with mapping
the night sky we're getting there
so Henrietta decides to make a graph to
start to plot every one of these stars
that are pulsating and determine if
there's any sort of pattern on one axis
she put how long it took for the Stars
cycles to go from bright to dim maybe it
was two days maybe it was five days
maybe it was ten days remember that each
of these stars were showing a very
consistent pattern of sticking to their
cycle on the other axis she plotted how
bright they were at each of these phases
at their dimmest and at their brightest
point so you've got brightness on this
side and you've got how long it takes
for this pulsating to happen on this one
so let's say she sees a star she sees
that it takes two days for it to go from
dim to bright and then two more days to
go from right to dim and then at its
dhimmis point it's brightness value is
down here and at its brightest point
it's more like up here so this is what
an entry would look like for one of
these stars that she's observing she did
this for a bunch of stars night after
night and she started to see a pattern
what this graph tells us is that stars
that have a really long cycle going from
dim to bright let's say they take like
ten or twenty days to do that those
stars are overall really bright they're
probably big they have more energy
whereas the opposite is true stars that
pulsate really quickly that maybe just
take a day or a half a day to go from
dim to bright dim to bright those stars
are actually overall much dimmer
potentially small
not actually as bright and intense as
these stars that take a really long time
to do their cycle so now if you look at
the night sky and you see a really dim
star let's say you don't know if it's
dim because that's just a really small
star or it's dim because it's really
really really far away and it's actually
a super bright star but it's just super
far away from our perspective so it
looks dim but now with Henrietta's
formula you could look at the pulsating
of that star and if it's pulsating
really slow taking ten days to go from
dim to bright and bright to dim then you
can be sure that that's actually a
really big bright star that just looks
dim to us because we're super far away
from it
this gave astronomers a yardstick that
they just didn't have before to observe
and understand the distance to stars
that were way way outside of the
previous tools that we had to measure
distance it took another swath of the
cosmos and took them from 2d to 3d
[Music]
soon after Henrietta Leavitt discovered
this amazing relationship a man by the
name of Edwin Hubble famous astronomer
decided that he wanted to use this to
settle the grand debate on whether or
not the galaxy was all there was to the
universe he had been looking up at the
sky and been seeing this kind of fuzzy
cluster of stars that he didn't really
understand
was it close was it far away Hubble was
able to pick out one of the stars in
this cluster and look at how it pulsated
using Henrietta's formula it became very
clear to Hubble that this little fuzzy
dot in the sky was very far away way
outside of our galaxy this settled the
debate about whether or not our galaxy
was the entire universe or not that
little fuzzy spot in the sky that Hubble
was looking at turned out to be the end
dromeda galaxy it was a groundbreaking
discovery all made possible because
Henrietta Leavitt formula and at the
time Hubble estimated that it was
probably around 700 thousand light years
away we've since honed that estimate -
more like 2.5 million light years away
and now using the telescope that bears
Hubble's name we've been able to observe
that there aren't just a few galaxies
outside of our own but billions okay
that's it that's the answer to my
question that's how I'm able to zoom
around the solar system and the galaxy
using this computer program the methods
I talked about here are kind of the main
building blocks of measuring distance in
space we're continuing to push the
bounds on this there are now methods for
measuring the distance to all sorts of
types of galaxies all sorts of types of
distances and we continue to build out a
map of the night sky in 3d and I'm
really grateful for that honestly I'm
grateful for the pioneers who put their
minds to giving us perspective because
it allows me to see where I live in the
cosmos and what kind of space I occupy
in the night sky and for some reason
that perspective knowing where the stars
are knowing how far away they are just
kind of has engrained itself into my
mind and allowed me to keep perspective
as I live my day to day life anyway
that's that thanks for watching also
I want to thank Squarespace for
sponsoring this video Squarespace is
really easy to use place where you can
build a website or a portfolio or an
online presence of any kind
I am currently rebuilding my portfolio
and website using Squarespace I'm
learning a ton about these features and
how useful they are there are really
easy to use beautiful templates that
allow you to get a website up in minutes
but then in addition to just like
hosting and websites
Squarespace gives you integration with
all sorts of things that make running an
online business easier and better like
email marketing campaigns and of course
integration with social media platforms
all of the tools you need to build out a
beautiful-looking online presence and to
do it without a ton of work Squarespace
is giving a discount to anyone who goes
to my unique URL squarespace.com slash
Johnny Harris it's in the description as
well make sure to use that URL as it
supports this channel if you do and if
you do you get a free trial you can get
everything set up and you'll get 10% off
any purchase of a domain name or hosting
space if you go to that URL so
definitely go check out Squarespace
thanks to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video and thank you all for
watching and looking forward to reading
comments and hearing your thoughts on
this stuff and I'm excited to make a new
video soon have a good day